it's triple the trouble times two for
darren and kelsey van der walk the
southern alberta ranching couple and
their three kids got quite the surprise
this week during a routine calving check
there was a kathleen in the field and
the mom had
one foot coming out of her so we decided
to pull it
quick the twin
before we headed to town
and then when we were when we were
pulling it i just made a joke that i
should check for one more and there was
another one two bull calves and one
heifer make up this trio all are doing
well now but mom does need some help
wrangling and feeding her new herd three
cats for one cow would be overwhelming
for sure some of them can raise too in
certain circumstances
yeah one will definitely go on it and
we'll find mamas for the for the other
ones the chances of seeing triplets in
beef cattle is rare especially for them
all to survive
i think the the odds are 105 thousand to
one or the odds and i pencil it out that
would have to count for 466 more years
for it to maybe happen again
the van der waals farm has some good
luck when it comes to calves and not
just because kelsey is also a mixed
animal veterinarian if you can believe
it triplets were born on the farm before
the owners of this place previous
his mom had in her diary that in 1959
they had a cow
that had
triplets here the birth order of the
cavs just so happens to line up the same
as their kids so picking names was an
easy choice their names match the middle
names of the kids
yeah john james and lynn
all together this threesome weighs in at
a little more than 200 pounds with
calves ranging from roughly 55 to 75
pounds each
quinn campbell global news